I want to take up in volume 13 at September the 2nd, 1921.
One who goes out of the divine will goes out to meet all miseries.
They're all the miseries of the human will.
Louisa said, "I was lamenting to my dear Jesus because of these blessed writings, which
they want to put out."
That means to publicize.
And she said, "I felt as if I wanted to withdraw from his will."
And so my sweet Jesus told me, "My daughter, what is this?"
You'd want to withdraw from my will, but it's too late.
You see, this is volume 13.
And in volume one, Louisa had three spiritual marriages.
So she's locked into union with God in an absolutely extraordinary way.
And what we're looking at is Louisa's feelings being expressed.
And so Jesus clarifies for her the difference between your will and your feelings.
It's too late to go out of the divine will, he said, "After you yourself bound yourself
in my will and my will bound you but with double chains to itself in order to keep you
safer."
Louisa agreed to these spiritual marriages.
So she agreed to this covenant with God.
A spiritual marriage is a covenant and a covenant is a spiritual marriage.
And God has been trying to have covenants with the human race from the very beginning, as
we saw with Abraham, as we saw with Moses, as we saw with King David, and so on.
So he said, "You bound yourself.
That is your yes, your fiat.
And we know that she made that fiat in the divine will.
My will bound you with double chains to itself in order to keep you safer.
You have lived as a queen in my will because he's the king.
You have accustomed yourself to living with most delicate and nourishing foods.
That's all the food that comes from Jesus' own love and his revelation of the divine
will to her.
Comitable by anyone but dominator of all, even of yourself.
In this union in the divine will, one of the extraordinary things is that we become masters
of our own self.
And this makes us very different to the vast majority of people on the earth who can be
slaves to their own bodies or slaves to their own feelings or slaves to materialism or power
or whatever it is.
And so anybody living in the divine will is free.
God makes you free.
And free of yourself is the greatest freedom of all, because the self is the greatest enslaver
on the earth.
You're the dominator of all, even of yourself.
You're used to living with all the comforts immersed in immense riches.
Now listening to Louisa talking about the amount of suffering she's been through, you'd never
think she was living with comforts, but of course she has these daily visits from God
Himself.
How many of us have the Lord coming to us throwing his arms around us?
How many of us have the Lord saying to us personally so that our ears can actually hear
it?
I love you with an immense love.
We know He does love us, but we haven't had this comfort.
Louisa had had an awful lot of comforts.
And you've been immersed in immense riches.
They're all the extraordinary graces and privileges that have been given to her.
If you go out of my will, you will notice immediately, as Adam did in Genesis 3, that
as soon as you go out of it, you will feel all the misery, the coldness and the lost dominion.
That's exactly what chapter 3 of Genesis tries to tell us, the absolutely extraordinary
change that happened instantly to Adam and Eve when they went out at the divine will.
All goods will disappear from you.
And from being a queen, you will become the most miserable servant.
Let me give you John 8.35 there, anyone who sins is a slave, Jesus said.
You yourself, upon feeling the great contrast that exists between living in my will and
going out of it, you will plunge yourself even more into the depths of my will.
This is why I say to you, it's too late and then you would take a great contentment away
from me also because it is such an unusual thing for the Lord to have somebody really
surrendered to him that that's his joy on the earth, that somebody loves him like this.
So the secret for us, whenever we are having difficulties or doubts or temptations, is
to simply plunge ourselves totally into the sea of the divine will and stay there.
Don't think about abandoning yourself, just dive in and just keep saying to him, day
and night, I abandon myself to you completely, I abandon myself to you completely.
He hears it the first time, but you might hear it the 20th time.
He takes it on board the first time you say it, but it might take you a much longer to
get through to yourself.
So the Lord can say to us, yes, it's too late because once you make this commitment,
absolutely permanent change has happened in the kingdom of God and if it's in the divine
will, it's permanent eternal.
And so Jesus said, you must know that I acted with you like a king who begins to love a
friend, a friend who is very dissimilar to him and status.
Now this story that's going to be told now, you will find in Ezekiel chapter 16 verses
4 to 19 as the origin of the vocation of the chosen people.
We are nothing of ourselves, it's what he makes of us.
So here's a king begins to love somebody who is very dissimilar to him and status.
So the king is the ruler and this person he chooses to love is a nobody.
And his love is so great that he has decided to make the friend similar to himself.
So he's the king and he's got all this power.
He can do this if he wants.
Now this king cannot do everything at once and render his friend like himself.
He has to do it little by little and this is very important.
One of us can take sudden change.
We find psychological and spiritual and even physical change quite difficult.
You will know that if you've ever moved house.
You'll know that if there ever has been a bereavement in your family.
Sudden permanent change is very difficult for us and takes us quite a time to adapt.
So if the Lord is to make us like himself he can only do it piece by piece so that we
will adapt and not go into a crisis.
That's why he has given us this revelation of the divine will now in 13 volumes.
And yet you know we will only be halfway through his message when we get to volume 18.
He's giving it to us piece by piece so that we can step into it as he reveals it to us.
So the Lord prepares a royal palace for his friend.
That's John 14 verses one and two.
I'm going to prepare a place for you and there's room for everybody in my father's
house because that's the extraordinary thing about God is that his love is universal and
his love is without boundaries.
It even includes you and me.
So he first of all prepares a royal palace for him similar to his own and he sends the
adornments to dress up this palace or adorned this palace.
He forms a little army for him and then he gives him half of his kingdom.
So as to be able to say what you possess I possess.
I am the king and you also are king but of course he's king with the capital K and we're
king with the little K because we have to learn how to be king over ourselves first.
However, each time the king would give his friend his gifts he would look at his faithfulness
in other words that's the test and you know from the scriptures that every single friend
of God has been tested.
If you haven't been tested I would worry.
He would look for his faithfulness, be faithful and attentive.
And giving the gift would be for the king an occasion for a new contentment, greater glory
and honor for himself and a new feast in other words love lives by giving.
And so he rejoices when the friend is willing to accept the gift that is being offered.
Now if the king had wanted to give to his friend all at once that which he had given
him little by little he would have embarrassed the friend because the friend was not trained
to be able to dominate it would be too much.
It's like our image of Cinderella.
One minute she's sitting in a kitchen looking after the most basic things in her house and
the next minute she's dressed as a glorious princess marrying a prince.
Human beings are not able to adapt to that kind of transformation all of a sudden.
And so Jesus says here you know you wouldn't be able to do it you wouldn't even be trained
to rule but little by little through his faithfulness he has been instructed so everything's
easy for him.
So if you get it incrementally you can adapt almost without even thinking.
And you can accept things then that you wouldn't have been able to accept if it was all given
at the same time.
So I want to give you Psalm 85 verses 10 to 13 that righteousness come down from heaven
and it looks for faithfulness to come up from the earth.
So Jesus said to Louisa this is what I did with you having chosen you in a special way
to live at the height of my will now that the word height there means at the summit.
We would say the summit of the mountain.
Mountains can be different height.
So in English if you want to talk about the tip top it's the summer.
So I want you to live in the summit or in the fullness of my will.
I've instructed you piece by piece little by little making it known to you.
And as I kept making it known I enlarged your capacity you see only the Lord knows what
he's doing.
And each time he gives us another grace in the divine will he opens more space for himself
in our soul in our interior.
He enlarges our capacity to take what he's offering so that when we remain faithful and
we accept gratefully whatever he gives to us that we grow and grow and grow and grow and
in the end we could take huge gulps of something that in the beginning we couldn't even have
taken a sip of our capacity has become greater.
So as I keep making this knowledge known to you I enlarge your capacity and I prepare
you for further and greater knowledge.
So in other words the little universe inside of you begins to expand and grow.
And of course the more it expands and grows the more it can develop and the more complex
can be the new creation that God does within us.
Every time I manifest to you one value or one effect of my will I feel a greater contentment
and together with heaven I make feast because now the New Jerusalem is being built on the
earth even if it is only in one person at this particular point which is Louisa.
Now as these truths of mine go out to be spread among other people you double my contentments
and my feasts therefore let me do he keeps pleading with her to give him the freedom
to do what he alone can do and you should plunge yourself more into my will.
Now the secret for us is simply to abandon ourselves to the divine will don't think
about it just do it be like the child who stands on the diving board and a swimming pool and
instead of saying oh my god it's 20 feet down to the water what will I do what will
I do what will I do the one who succeeds in the the dive is the one who doesn't look
takes a deep breath and jumps and then they're in the water completely abandoned to the water
then their skills at swimming can go into place but if we keep thinking and thinking and thinking
and doing novenas about surrender to the divine will I don't think we're going to get there
close your eyes take a deep breath and go and say to the Lord I jump I jump now I jump
now into the deepest steps of your divine will I don't care about the consequences you
will look after that and you'll look after me but jump and give your God great joy you
should plunge yourself more and more into my will Jesus said so September the 6th 1921
as the truths are known new union with Jesus is formed Jesus wants to make known what his
will did in his humanity in order to constitute the new generations as heirs of his will now
what Jesus is going to say to us here is that he has not come to continue the usual revelations
that he has given to other saints he revealed his passion to other people like Anne Catherine
Emric just to take one example he has revealed immense things about his mercy to sister Faustina
he revealed wonders about the sacred heart to Margaret Mary alla coke other saints have
received wonderful things he's not repeating himself God never repeats himself he wants
to do something new he always wants to do something new he always wants to let his creativity
have an outlet so here he is going to reveal more and more things to Louisa about the interior
life that he had in his divine will during his life on earth and eternally and how he
wants that to be manifested in us so that the church picks up the living in the divine
will up to this point the church has lived in the humanity of Jesus through him with him
and in him as we've been told but it was the humanity of Jesus and we have looked at the
passion from an external viewpoint now we've got to go deeper and we've got to go internal
before it was add extra now it's add intra and he wants to take us there and he wants us
to participate so Louisa said I was fusing all of myself in the divine will to see we're
at this again I fuse all of me in all of you all the time I was fusing all of myself in
the holy will of my sweet Jesus and I said to him my love I enter into your will and here
I find all the thoughts of your mind and all the thoughts of the people from Adam to Zachary
everyone on the planet I surround your thoughts with my thoughts and with the thoughts of
my brothers and sisters and then because you can do anything in the divine will the divine
will is the creative power of God and we need to sort of grasp the extraordinary power we
have in the divine will so she says I can access your thoughts in the divine will I can access
the thoughts of every human being from Adam to Zachary and now she said I want to unite
these two sets of thoughts together I want to make them one in order to give you Lord
the homage the adoration the glory the love the reparation of your own intelligence isn't
that wonderful there's your prayer you don't need to be any cleverer than that and while
I was saying this my Jesus moved in my interior and moved in my interior means the kingdom
of God is already there so that's Luke 17 21 and it's one Corinthians 3 16 you'll hear
me say that over and over again to remind you that Jesus is operating from within her
so the kingdom of God is within as Luke 17 21 says and he said inseparable to offer now
inseparable because she's had three spiritual marriages she is living in the divine will
she's not living in her own will and so she has gone over to the heavenly dimension of
life and in the early volumes you only ever heard Jesus say that his mother was his inseparable
mother now he has a mother on earth because he called Louisa a mother from volume two
and he's now calling her his inseparable mother on earth now we also have to move to
the place where he can call us his inseparable brides inseparable daughter of my will he
said how happy I am in hearing repeated what my humanity did in my will so when Louisa
joined the thoughts of the human race to the thoughts of Jesus and in the divine will brought
them together to unify them and then offer them to God she was doing what Jesus had been
doing and that's what we have to do we have got to look understand repeat and echo him
inseparable daughter of my will how happy I am in hearing repeated what my humanity
did in my will and I kiss your thoughts in mine your words in mine your heartbeat in mine
now your thoughts because she has fused herself completely in him your words because that's
the prayer that she's offering and your heartbeat that's the love with which she's operating
and as he was saying this he covered all of me with kisses so there you have the divine
lover and I said to him my life why do you enjoy so much and make feast every time you
manifest another effect of your will now he's already told her but Jesus knows that we're
going to need to hear this over and over at nausea before it really registers with us and
so he said you must know that every time I manifest to you one more truth about my will
it is one more bond that I form between you and me he's already told about these bonds
and I formed them with the human family why because in the divine will we are led to connect
the thoughts of the human race to his thoughts the words of the human race to his words the
actions of the human race to his to try and bring about that union that needs to happen
if we're going to have the second Pentecost you must know that every time I manifest to
you one more truth about my will it's one more bond that I form between you and me and
with the whole human family it's a greater union each time it's a tighter link each time
it's a shearing in my inheritance he said now it's the child who gets the inheritance
as you know and people living in the divine will are the true children of God Romans 819
so you can put Romans 819 there the true children of God and as I manifest these truths Jesus
said I formed the deed of donation in other words he's saying that the more he manifests
of his divine will the more he is saying to us I will give this kingdom to you all you've
got to do is listen learn put into practice and call that kingdom into being and do your
bit to let it happen on the earth and he will do the rest and as I manifest these truths
I form the deed of donation and in seeing my children richer and sharing in the inheritance
I feel new contentment in other words we make him very happy it's the same with me as with
a father who possesses much land and this land is actually unknown to his children what's
the point in telling a three year old that your father has a hundred acres of land the
child doesn't know what an acre is and the child thinks that the first field outside the
house is endless so the child doesn't have a concept of a massive farm the child doesn't
have a concept of hundreds and hundreds of cows and sheep it can see a few of them but
it can see the whole herd and that's the way we are that somehow we know we're on the farm
we know that we're the children of the family we know we have this relationship with the
father we know that there's a great inheritance out there but we don't grasp it at all don't
have an idea so the land is unknown to his children they do not know that they are the
children of a father who is so rich I often describe Catholics as people who sit outside
of a bank that they own starving to death because when you look at the way we behave
in church we have been told so much about the Holy Eucharist and yet do we grasp what
it's about we've been told about the wonders of the Holy Rosary do we grasp it we've been
told that Jesus is present in the Blessed Sacrament do we grasp it if you look at the
way people behave you'll realize they don't they don't even believe it they just think
it's a nice idea a reality that God is with us no they don't get it they don't realize
they are children of a father who is so rich now as the children grow up and come of age
the father keeps telling them day after day that he actually owns such and such a farm
so it's not a major farm that he owns he owns the whole province he might even own
the whole country and that farm is mine and that farm is mine and that they begin children
begin to realize my goodness we had no idea on hearing this the children make feast and
they cling to the father with a greater bond of love in seeing the feast of the children
the father makes feast and prepares for them another greater surprise saying to them such
and such a province is mine so he isn't just we're living on a farm he isn't just a lord
of it an area such and such a province is mine and then as they're able to somehow take
it on board he says such and such a kingdom is mine who is this man that we have been
calling father the children begin to realize they didn't know their father at all that's
our tragedy we don't really know God and at some point we need to open the whole of
our being to him and say lord show yourself to me let me know who my father is let me
know whose child I am so that I may rejoice and that I may participate in your kingdom
as you want so as the revelation gets deeper and deeper the children are enchanted and
they not only celebrate but they believe themselves fortunate to be the children of
this father as we grow to realize that we're the most fortunate people on the planet knowing
about the divine will knowing how many others won't even consider it and the father not
only makes his possessions known to his children but he constitutes them heirs of his goods
we're not only children we're heirs that's the incredible thing and you get that in Romans
eight we are not only children we are heirs now the same happens to me he said up until
now that means the 19th centuries before he began dealing with Louisa I have made known
what my humanity did that's the old era I made known its virtues and its pains in order
to constitute the human family as heir of the goods of my humanity so that was stage one
now I want to move forward so 20th century new era and the new era is being revealed
first it has to be revealed otherwise we can't move into it now I want to move forward so
I want to give you therefore Isaiah 43 I can't remember the verses at this moment and but
it says there's no need to remember the past behold I'm doing a new thing even now it comes
to light can you not see it I want to move forward and I want to make known to humanity
what my will did in my humanity so as to constitute the new generations as heirs of my will so
the extraordinary thing is that Jesus is talking to Louisa at a time when they have worked
their way through the first world war and they're in this terrible period between the
first world war and the second world war where everything is going downhill on the earth
and here he is making a completely new era it's just incredible okay so I want to give
you Jeremiah 29 11 where he says that if you come to me and sincerely seek me you will
find me and he's creating this new era okay I am I am making something completely new
and wonderful for you so there's humanity tearing itself apart and he creating something
new and wonderful for us so you see the way God's love is working and you see the way
humanity's sin is working the contrast is unbelievable so he said I want to move forward
and I want to make known to the human race what my will did in my humanity so as to constitute
the new generations as heirs to my will now up to the 20th century the church and the true
believers were heirs to his humanity now are going to be heirs to his divine will of course
I don't have to tell you we have done zero and a million percent below zero to deserve
this as Paul tells us in his letter to the Romans that where sin abounds grace stuff even
more abounds so that's Romans chapter three around verse 20 so therefore he said be attentive
in listening to me and do not lose anything of the effects and the value of this will of
mine so that you may be faithful a faithful relater of these goods the first bond of union
with my will and of communication with the other creatures he is going to set up this
kingdom Louisa is going to be the first because our blessed mother is in a completely different
place so Louisa is going to be the first and it's like as if the foundation stone is put
in with Louisa and then the other stones are gathered around her and he begins to build
the house but only he can build the house because the Sams tell us unless the Lord builds the
house they labor in vain who build it there's nothing we can't do it it's his work and we
saw in Matthew 16 that Jesus said to Peter in the Apostles no I will build my church and
then on Mount Tabor Peter showed how little he had heard and he said I will build for
you three tenths and God himself had to stop him he said listen to my son only Jesus can
build this kingdom it's his kingdom and he has paid for everything he's the only one
who has rights the rest of us have privileges and so the enormity of the privilege involved
should make us die of gratitude for just simply that he has your name on the list so let's
take September the 14th 1921 each time the soul does her acts in the divine will she grows
more and more in sanctity this means that the level of sanctity that you reach is entirely
in your hands now we're used to being told in this coronavirus pandemic that your health
is in your hands your safety is in your hands but the sanctity that we reach is also in our
hands because it depends on the number of acts that we're prepared to do so Jesus said to
Louisa my daughter each time the soul does her acts in my will she grows more and more
before me in wisdom in goodness in power and in beauty now that's something isn't it to
grow in wisdom goodness power and beauty that means that we are being reordered into the
divine image I want to give you two Corinthians 3 18 for that that we become like that which
we worship and it's each time so in fact as she keeps repeating her acts in my will she
takes more bites of wisdom and goodness etc now picture little children in a family and
mother has made very nice goodies and she has put them in small little bonds and cakes
but she has wisely caught them very small so that they're bite size and she puts them
on a plate in the middle of the table and then you just have to watch she sends the children
out into the playroom to go and play or out into the garden or whatever they find a hundred
and two excuses for coming into the kitchen and when she appears not to be watching another
little bond disappears and another one and another one and they're all gone that's what
Jesus is doing with us in revealing these wonderful truths to us he's putting these bite
size bonds in front of us and watching pretending isn't watching and smiling as we come along
and say oh I like that I certainly like growing in wisdom and goodness and power and beauty
I don't know about you and the soul grows with the food from which she feeds herself these
are the bite size pieces that Jesus is giving us in each one of these messages but unfortunately
for me I could spend forever on one of them and I have to keep going because I have to
give you a comment you could stay forever on any one of these things this is why in the
holy gospel it is written that I grew in age and wisdom and grace before God and man that's
Luke 240 why because he was doing the acts in the divine will who doing them for us he
was actually rebuilding humanity making a divine version of each one of us as God I could
neither grow nor decrease my growth was just in my humanity which growing in age came to
multiply my acts in the supreme volition that's what I said and what we have to do is imitate
re echo repeat and each additional act I did was additional growth in the wisdom of the
celestial father so where do we get the wisdom in order to be able to teach divine will material
to new generations we get it by chewing this bite by bite and by accepting this in the
depths of our being because it's only then you will be able to share it with others but
you will reach a point that you will be so full that if you don't share it with others
you'll burst you must cherish with others the lord knows what he's doing he said in
john 7 37 to 39 come and drink come and drink if you really wanted come and drink and he
said out of your own heart will flow fountains of living water and fountains of living water
means plenty of food for others fountains there will be a continuous flow and Jesus continues
this growth of mine in age and wisdom and grace before God and man was so real that even creatures
noticed it in the end people will notice they will gradually notice that you are very different
to other people they'll notice your peace they'll notice your calm they'll notice your
humanity they'll notice there is something about you they'll notice you're different
they'll begin to come to you looking for advice that is a recognition of the wisdom and the
discernment in other words they do actually tell you you've grown Jesus continues each
one of my acts ran in the immense sea of the divine will and as I operated I nourished
myself with this celestial food I want to give you John 4 32 where Jesus told the apostles
that he had food to eat that they knew nothing about and then he continues to tell them my
food is to do with the will of the one who sent me his food was the divine will Jesus
continues it would take too long to tell you of the seas of wisdom and goodness and beauty
and power that my humanity swallowed in every additional act it performed now why could he
swallow whole seas of wisdom and goodness and beauty and power it's because he was the
sinless one he was that song and he was God he could take the whole thing try and imagine
someone being able to drink an ocean look at the capacity that's in his soul and so my
comparison we're not even a drop and yet that little drop can increase and increase and increase
as we do our acts and so having told us about how he grew himself Jesus says the same thing
happens to the soul my daughter he said sanctity in my will grows in every instant can I say
that again sanctity in my will grows in every instant there's nothing that can escape growing
at the soul there's nothing that the soul cannot let flow in the infinite sea of my will the
most indifferent things sleep food work etc they can all enter into my will and they can
take their place of honor as agents of my will so don't think that you've got to be
saying acts all the time you've got to be conscious of operating in the divine will and
conscious of operating at the divine level and every now and then you need to remind
him to remind you that you're staying fused all of you in all of him all the time so that
everything thoughts words actions motivations desires everything everything is on his level
it's divine so you're operating in the divine will having your lunch sweeping the floor washing
the dishes pulling up the weeds in the garden whatever if the soul only wants it everything
from the greatest to the smallest action can be occasions to enter into my will and this
doesn't happen when you're on the level of the virtues because if you're operating the
virtue of obedience you need somebody to actually give you an obedience if you're operating
on the level of patience you need someone to make you feel impatient but with the divine
will it's all the time every nanosecond I think it's brilliant in fact if one wants to exercise
the virtues many times the occasion is missing as I've just said if the soul wants to exercise
obedience to take someone to command her and it may happen that for days and weeks there's
no one there to give you a command therefore as much goodwill to obey as she might have
poor obedience has to be idle the same with patience or humility and any the other virtues
since these are virtues of the low world the low world is art and the low world also represents
a lower level of spirituality as well and it's slower and it's more ponderous and there's
an awful lot more struggle in it and everything whereas living in the divine will is living
as an eagle living at the highest level of your being living up in the mountains in the
glorious air of God's divine breath so the virtues are in virtues of the low world and
other creatures are needed in order to exercise them on the other hand my will is the virtue
of heaven and I alone am enough to keep the soul in every instant in continuous exercise
therefore in this time of lockdown that we're in it's the most extraordinary time of grace
God has put us all on retreat it's the most wonderful thing I don't know about you but
I'm thoroughly enjoying it on the other hand my will is the virtue of heaven and I alone
am enough to keep the soul in every instant in continuous exercise it is easy for me to
keep her up above night and day in order to keep her exercised in my will so up above
is where the eagles live down below is where the squalling seagulls are fighting for food
on ground level so it's up to us whether we want to be an eagle or a seagull September
the 16th 1921 Jesus is mocked by Herod how these pains are renewed by creatures I was
doing the hour of the passion in which my sweet Jesus was in the palace of Herod clothed
as a madman and mocked and he told me my daughter not only then was I clothed it like
a madman sneered at and mocked but creatures continue to give me these pains even more
I am amidst continuous mockery and by all kinds of people if a person goes to confession
and does not maintain his resolutions not to offend me this is a mockery that he makes
of me because the confession is not valid at all unless we have the firm resolution of
amendment if a priest confesses preaches administers the sacraments and his life does not correspond
to the words that he says and to the dignity of the sacraments that he administers he mocks
me as many times for as many words as he says and for as many sacraments as he administers
that's very frightening while I gave them new life in the sacraments they give me scorn
and mockery and by profaning them they prepare for me a garment to clothe me as a madman isn't
that frightening if superiors command sacrifice virtue prayer and disinterest to their subjects
while they conduct a life of comfort vice and interest these are many mockery that they
make of me if civilian and ecclesiastical leaders want the observance of laws they are the first
transgressors these are mockeries that they make of me it's not fantastic oh how many
mockeries they make of me there are so many that I'm tired of them especially when they
put the poison of evil under the cloak of good that's one of the things that Jesus could
not take was hypocrisy so I want to give you Matthew 23 but I also want to give you a
Matthew 15 and I think it's verses 1 to 10 it's the whole of Matthew 23 and Jesus uncovers
the dreadful hypocrisy of the spiritual leaders of Israel in his own day it's not any different
to today and so while Matthew 23 and Matthew 15 1 to 10 it's not comfortable reading it
actually exposes one of the reasons why the church is very very sick today very sick hypocrisy
really means that you wear the clothes of a religious person and you say religious things
and you do religious actions but you are not serving God you are serving yourself or you're
serving the world or even worse you're serving Satan in other words you're an actor we all
know that the habit doesn't make the monk it's the monk that makes sense of the habit
oh how they make fun of me Jesus said as if I was their amusement in their pastime but
sooner or later justice will make fun of them in other words when the cup is overflowing
justice will come and the immense immeasurable mercy of God gives us more and more and more
time to repent I think this lockdown time is time to repent time to get our act together
time to go serving God time to go seeking God sooner or later justice will make fun
of them by punishing them severely they should pray and they should repair for these
mockeries that they give me so much and they are the cause for which I do not make myself
known for who I am here Jesus is saying something that is all over the Old Testament and that
is the prophets of old made it perfectly clear that whenever the chosen people got into trouble
with God in other words they fell into idolatry and the sin that goes with it or they got
really worldly and into world politics and all this kind of stuff whenever that happened
the prophets laid the blame squarely at the feet of the priests the so-called prophets
the ones that were paid by the king and the leaders so the religious leaders and the political
leaders it is exactly the same today the people won't go astray if they have good shepherds
the worst thing that can happen is that you don't have a good shepherd afterwards
it's coming back again Jesus as I was fusing all of myself in his holy will told me now
notice she's just had a revelation from the Lord and she's had three spiritual marriages
and yet she is personally consciously fusing herself in the divine will all the time that's
the key for us it doesn't matter where you think you are in your relationship with God
it doesn't matter how wonderful you think your relationship with God is we have got to keep
up the fusing Jesus said dearest offer of mine I anxiously await your fusions in my will
now how important is that you must know that as I thought in my will I kept molding your
thoughts in my will preparing the place for them as I worked I molded your works in my
will as so with all the rest now whatever I did I did not do for myself since I did not
need it I did it for you you meaning the human race this is why I await you in my will so
that you may come all of you not just Louisa all of us and take the places which my humanity
prepared for you that's John 14 to in my father's house there's a place for you and
over my moldings come and do yours in other words echo and repeat only then am I content
and receive complete glory when I see you do what I did I'm going to stop there this